a Fox News contributor for some reason
that serves only propaganda purposes
wore a tactical vest
one that was hilariously too small by
the way until he put on one that was
more appropriate appropriately sized at
the us-mexico border implying that there
is such danger there that he needs to be
protected with a tactical vest we've
talked about these media stunts before
but usually they don't serve political
purposes so much as they serve
sensationalism purposes and usually it's
weather related we've joked and talked
about when you see reporters waiting in
floodwaters that actually aren't very
deep or being in a canoe and flood
waters that turn out to be no more than
six inches deep as somebody walks by or
standing out in weather that appears to
be extraordinarily windy and out
completely out of control as people
casually walk by wearing athletic gear
in the past and for the most part these
media stunts are first sensationalist
purposes there's not necessarily like a
political agenda there it's trying to
make interesting visually compelling
television this gets us the last week
and we're in the thick of the
immigration and border wall Fiasco
including Donald Trump's failed Mexico
will pay for the wall promise
the conflict between Donald Trump and
his department of homeland security
secretary Kirsten Nielsen who of course
resigned yesterday all of this stuff we
have this fox news contributor named
Lawrence Jones the third who was
previously parroted all sorts of
completely heinous conspiracy theories
he went to the border to appear on Sean
Hannity's program last week and he wore
what is being described as a tactical
vest now this first one that we have on
screen for you here doesn't appear to be
bullet proof it's also comically small
but this is part of a propaganda war
that is being waged now in another
picture he's wearing a different vest
and you'll notice he's posing with a
Border Patrol agent who is not similarly
protective protected that is seems that
between the first picture with the tiny
tactical vest and the later television
appearance he realized that the thing he
was wearing looked completely idiotic
and he put on something that was a
little
or appropriately-sized the idea is if
you go to the US border it's so
dangerous that you need to be wearing a
tactical or otherwise bulletproof vest
and as it happens this thing was just
visual it wasn't at least the first one
wasn't even really a bulletproof vest
but that's just part of the theater of
this entire thing
he claims that agents forced him to wear
it for safety
even though actual border agents in the
area were seen not wearing protective
gear I wonder whether his camera person
during this appearance was similarly
wearing protective gear and it's all
about playing up the narrative the
narrative is the border is dangerous the
border is chaotic it's sort of like a
war zone which is why this guy had to be
protected in this way and of course
there are countless reporters who have
reported from the border and made clear
they've never worn such vests real or
fake it's not dangerous even when riding
along with Border Patrol they still
haven't been told that they need to dawn
such apparel and the propaganda
narrative of a dangerous war zone at the
border this is a sort of more cartoonish
way of playing up the narrative but you
need to understand that this is not very
different from when Donald Trump says
we're sending troops to the border this
is the same propaganda narrative Trump
has more resources to play with he can
play up the dangerous war zone us-mexico
border narrative by deploying National
Guard troops Lawrence Jones the third
doesn't have those resources so he puts
on a vest but it is all part of the
exact same propagandizing sensational
sensationalizing of the United States
Mexico border wall status quo and just
because Lawrence Jones the third doesn't
have the resources Trump has to make as
big of a show of it it's playing up that
exact same widely debunked narrative